do you 101 it's not a troll and
everybody watch dicho the deed shows me
like um da da da Salam alaykoum that's
the wonderful greeting of peace peace be
unto you thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show where
we're trying to help you understand
Islam and Muslims and Islam simply means
to acquire peace by submitting your will
to the owner of peace the one God the
creator of all that exists the crater of
man and woman the crater of the Sun and
the moon the crater of this whole
universe that's the one God we're
talking about now he has sent through
all time messengers and they came with
that same message worship the crater and
not his creation they came with a
comprehensive system on how the human
being needs to live his life but now
there's another part another facet to
this patients it requires some patience
to stay away from the evil things that
are out there calling you day and night
and how can we acquire this we need some
more advice we need teachers to teach us
qualified individuals and we want we got
one of those qualified individuals here
today he's back with us again sheikh
ibrahim zad am right back more on the
Dean show love there's only one
how much is his messenger Allah that
you're having
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice I said
I alaikum peace be with you how are you
sure thankful thank you for trying to
trying to be with us here again on the
Dean show your regular here it's always
a pleasure to me Ellis panel Tyler bless
this work and mellow Spanish Allah keep
me steadfast on his religion that he
choose for banking division immensely
amen I mean people can go to the Dean
show calm you have your own private
section there has your biography tells
the people a little bit about you who
you are what you're doing and the
previous shows we've done with you now
today because time is short we get
straight into the topic today we want to
talk about patience it requires a lot of
patience doing the good staying
steadfast on doing all the wonderful
things that the craters told us to do in
the verbatim word of god the Quran so we
want some advice because sometimes
people male and female they feel like
slipping it's hard to sometimes get up
for that early morning prayer you got to
be patient sometimes it's hard you want
to take that sip of some of that stuff
they'll make your mind go loose you know
what I mean you want to let loose but
you can't you gotta refrain so talk to
us about the importance of patients come
to love salatu salam a little patience
or it's an arabic called sub and the
world sub literally mean something that
is business that means it doesn't taste
good in the beginning and lost panel to
Allah the most merciful or that the
believers mentioned patients in the
Quran for over the 90 times in the whole
90 x 90 times on the phone over that
with regards to patients the rewards of
it the order from Allah subhanAllah life
for people to be patient and very would
for the people in the hereafter and in
this life and with these orders from
Allah subhana Allah it shows that when
the Most High created the human beings
everybody in do patients one way or the
other anybody most
non-muslims in our daily life lost panel
Tana created this life in such a way
that if we leave your home for example
without cleaning it for a few days it
becomes dirty you have to have patience
to clean it you have to have patience to
earn money you have to have patience to
study and people would look ahead that
he would earn after few years of
studying and hard work and things like
this how would a person steadfast and
his studying and his learning and so on
his my patience patience carry the
person to reach his goal this is effect
and a lot of the most high the most
merciful made this in the life of the
people so don't know so that nobody will
have an excuse saying I can't have
patience you already have patience in
many things and that's why when it comes
to matters of the hereafter worshiping
the creator of the heavens and the earth
at all obeying the orders of Allah
soprano Diana we have to have the hearts
attached to the hereafter this life is
short so short and everybody shall
depart from it so to be patient to seek
very words from the creator of the
heavens and the earth that a person
would receive in the hereafter that
needs patience that's why patients is of
three types as it's mentioned the Quran
to be patiently away from sins and the
things that are lost panatela for babe
by the way the sins in Islam as it's
mentioned in the Quran and the Sunnah of
the Prophet SAW hilario seller it's all
evil things the most high the most
merciful the most wise he did not forbid
his creation from something that is a
necessity in their life or something
that would bring any goodness to them
it's all the immediate passion or the
immediate attachment that if people
would look ahead and this is the
difference between the human beings and
others if they would just look ahead and
they would think and make right
decisions they would see that all these
things that are since it's something
that is all evil even if it being some
joy temporary joy that brings after that
misery in this life and in the year
after so to be patient away from sins
because we want to preserve our email
our faith the faith increases and
decreases increases with good deeds and
decreases with bad deeds and the sin is
not just a scent versus a good deed it
effects the heart it decreases the amend
it decreases the structure that you
built
with the good deeds and being obedient
to Allah span otona being in the state
of sin decreases all of it so that's why
this is something that would help the
believers to be always in state of
patience and many other reasons like
when a person went to the prophet saw
said when he told them give me the
permission to commit zina adultery the
prophets allah salam did not tell him
this is what are you asking for he said
do you like this for your mother do you
like this for your and do you like this
for your sister people would sound
nature they won't like these things for
their own selves so then the prophets
are seldom told them the same way people
don't like it for themselves you should
not like it for your own self and for
others so by thinking this way and this
is what we need to call people to do we
need to think many people on the face of
earth now they're not thinking properly
they're just busy with the daily
activities and the desires and things of
that nature they don't think to see what
is right and what is wrong I don't think
anybody on the face of earth would say
patience is a bad thing everybody would
agree patience is a good thing yes but
it depends on what are you trying to
achieve so being patient away from since
being being patient to apply the orders
of Allah soprano time as human beings we
tend to be lazy we don't like anybody to
tell us do this or not to do that but
when we know that this is something that
we are nothing but servants of the
creator of the heavens and earth we need
to humble ourselves to him we eat from
his provisions all the favors from Allah
is showers azzurro all around us that
means we need to be shy from him that we
be obedient to him and he said that
after the slave for those who are
obedient they would enter the gender of
a lost panel that so people need to be
peace is there a verse in the verbatim
word of God Almighty Allah the Quran
that Allah is saying can you explain is
that indeed those without account are
the patient those on that day that are
without account are the patient it's a
good point because many verses on the
quran with the rewards of good deeds you
would find the rewards 10 rewards
multiplications of that but when it came
to patients a lost panel tyler said what
you said here that the rewards is
without a limit in man you ever saw be
ruin at your home you later he said
that in the Marines indeed ufs lobby
rule which means the sabi rule those who
have patience they are given in full
their rewards without account without
limits without limit so if you do one
good deed you get 10 rewards right and
then it can be multiplied by here what
there is no limit to how much reward you
can be from holding back like the person
says some you offend you you want knock
them in the mouth you know I shouldn't
be doing I can't do that s'long doesn't
let me to hurt somebody so you're
patient for the Creator let's quit and
that's why it's a deed done by the heart
mm-hmm there's no such a thing as he's
patient meaning physically patient yeah
no it's something that its roots in the
huts and then it shows its effect in our
outside of you was there a hardy is
there a hadith where the Prophet peace
be upon he was sitting with Abu Bakr
Siddiq and this man came and can you go
ahead and liber8 he was insulting Abu
Bakr and the prophet and then the angels
were right can you go ahead and was this
about patients also right and the
prophets allah said them was being
revealed to him yes is one of the
benefits of the washi the revelation
from allah that we get to see the unseen
yeah and when the prophets are seldom
was seeing that and would seem that his
companion was patiently responding to
this person and then when he got angry
and he wanted to respond in an
unprincipled way the Prophet Sal are
seldom told them from the unseen that
the angels were supporting him while he
wasn't smiling back while he was in
patients pay she was practicing it yeah
and once he get it into himself as a
personal thing then the protection was
lifted he was left to his own self big
lesson furnace isn't it definitely and
that's why if a human being is left for
his own self he's perished yeah unless
we are protected by a las panel driver
and the creation of Allah span ocala we
are lost that's why if I if I go back to
the three parts of patients being
patient away from sins being patient to
do what a las palitana ordered us to do
in the way that Allah Allah Allah wants
us to do it the third type is to be
patient whenever a calamity hits we are
human beings and that's why if I have
the time I would like to give you or to
the viewers something to make it easy
for us let's hold off on that and we're
going to come back and go
on this to say to me why did you become
a Muslim no I give a very frivolous on
should i say i want to be on the side of
the angels [ __ ] is a guy she's a number
one rap artists in the world he sold
over 60 million records were 60 million
Steve million he was a young guy we're
basically everything that somebody who
would think that life is all about he
had everything you can imagine Dean show
back here on a Dean show with sheikh
ibrahim sedan please continue where you
left off before we went on a break
anything that happens in our life there
is something before it and there's
something after it if something happens
to us and something said has to happen I
would like this is the wisdom of the
creator of the heavens and new earth
either will die or someone that is a
loved one will die something bad happens
to a person so we need to prepare
ourselves for what's coming ahead by
having always been putting the trust in
allah subhan allah ta'ala by taking the
means the physical means that
permissible means why the hearts
attached to the creator of the heavens
and the earth putting our trust in him
that everything happened by the full and
the perfect wisdom of the Most High
nothing happens like that with other
wisdom and then if something bad happens
to the person immediately after that he
is pleased with the cuddler with the
destiny of a loss
I know that so you have as one of the
scholars give it that two things that
around the cutter around the destiny of
Allah that what could to put our trust
in Allah Hannah Tyler before it and to
be pleased and patient when it comes to
active what happened to the person why
because we are nothing but servants of
the creator of the heavens and the earth
and these are acts of worship yeah we
lose it sometimes you know it's a rat
race out there in life and things
getting the hustle and bustle and
traffic and this and that and sometimes
it's easier said than done but when we
hear from the last and final messenger
sent to mankind the same way Jesus was a
messenger at his time Moses Abraham they
were all calling the people to the same
thing and they had the ultimate gems of
wisdom because it was coming up from the
desires but from the creator of the
heavens and earth so when we hear some
of these sayings of the Prophet
authentic he's not lullabies or stories
fables these are authentic sayings so
can you elaborate another one because
did the Prophet peace be upon him said
the person also when he refrains from
from even when he's right but he doesn't
get into the argument what does it mean
a lot will kill him a house and Jenna
right this is again it's an actor voice
yeah active voice if that means we have
to submit ourselves to Allah soprano
Tyler the most high when it comes to the
sector which people reward one another
yes if people are nice to me I'm nice to
them if they're not nice to me I won't
be nice to them this is not an act of
which this is basically just rewarding
one another a lot of the Most High want
something else extra from them if people
are nice to you nice to them if they're
not nice to you you still need to be
obedient to Allah subhana Allah with
regarding to your affairs with them and
that's why when the prophet saw the
lower himself and peace be upon him what
he said when people are arguing and when
arguments comes in place it's not about
finding the truth it's about who would
win for his own personal glory so the
prophets are seldom said whoever leaves
argument while he is on the truth he
presented the truth the truth is clear
and one characteristic for the truth
that if it stands in front of the
falsehood the falsehood cannot stand in
front of it so he explained the truth
the Quran is so now the prophets are
seldom and the matter is clear but then
the other person still
to argue in that case the profits are
seldom said whoever leaves such argument
to a homo heck which means he is on the
right side he's on the truth I love the
most high would build a house for him in
the outskirts of gin and this is the
mercy of Allah soprano Donna because not
every human being can do this you are on
the right side you're not someone that
trying to prove something wrong you know
that you are correct and you would feel
that this person defeated you you might
think that he defeated you maybe your
ego also right definitely and that's why
one person's suppress this for the
benefit for the sake of the creator of
the heavens and earth alone a lost panel
Tana the most merciful nothing is wasted
and that's why one important statement
that we need to understand very well
that whoever leaves anything for the
sake of all or not for any worldly
benefit for the sake of the creator of
the heavens in the earth you would never
feel the loss of it never never if he's
truthfully leaving it for the sake of
the creator of heavens me so a male or
female doesn't matter doesn't matter it
might be something immediate feels it
needs some struggle and then eventually
after that he would he or she would feel
no loss whatsoever in what they left me
like we're all human beings yeah if
human being some of them would say I
cannot believe this whatever sin they
are doing other human beings if you give
them even push them to do it they would
rather be killed than to do the same
thing why is that when the temptations
are the same some people walked in
themselves they thought about it they
made decisions they turned to the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
it's just a short period of time and it
becomes in their norm but others are
they surrendered themselves to their
desires and they chose to live a life
like how the animals do yeah so we don't
want to live like the animals we want to
live like the Most High has told us to
live according to his guidance not our
desires and that is something logical
rational now let's get to the
nitty-gritty is from some real practical
examples you know that man is attracted
to women women a man and sometimes it
requires a lot of patience not to do it
the wrong way but to do it the right way
can you talk to us about this right this
is also something that is mentioned in
the Quran and in the life of the prophet
salla allah because allah spinel data is
the most merciful the family structure
in Islam is something very important it
is the right of every human being to be
raised
in a healthy family he sees the father
and the mother and there is no chaos in
the household with cheating and things
like this and that's why I lost panorama
protected us with the orders of Allah
Spinoza it's against one's desires if we
leave our desires to be the leading
thing to us either the desires would
lead us or the truth would lead us and
the desires comes after it if a lot of
the Most High forbidden adultery and
what comes before it this religion is so
perfect if adultery is forbidden then
what leads to it has to be forbidden
otherwise no human being except very few
if they are right by the sin and by the
real temptation most of the human beings
even if it's a righteous person would
fall into that scene that's why you so
family salon prophet yusuf RSM who have
a surah in the quran chapter mcallen
about him why because he was patient
when he faced the wife of the person in
Egypt she was a beautiful woman she has
status he was a slave to her that means
he has to obey her he was a stranger
that means if he do something nobody
would blame him she was ordering him she
was threatening him that he would be in
the prison if he does not commit this
act to her and he was a single man he
was not married that means all the means
of falling into the sin was there and
she closed the doors and everything but
that everything is ready for it but then
when he choose to have the fear of Allah
soprano Donna and he patiently stayed
away from that we still tell today how
many people in the face of earth even
now at this second that I'm speaking I
reciting surah Yousuf and his praises
being mentioned what would happen if he
had committed the sin nobody would have
heard about him but a las panel tyla
raised his mention as a result of being
patiently for just few minutes obeying
the orders of Allah spray on a patient
patient back to so that's why the orders
of Allah soprano Cara when it comes to
hey Jeb lowering the gays all of this is
to protect ourselves a protect our amen
our faith to protect our children to
protect the family to protect the
society in general all of that is from
the most y soprano Diana that's why when
a person as the prophets are seldom
which is a very good hadith we are weak
if a person falls into the sin
looking at something that is not
permissible for him to look the profits
are seldom said go back to your wife and
have relations with her because she has
what you saw because Sharon beautifies
in your eyes what you see and it's not
true exactly what you see is what you
see share time the devil is making it
more appealing than what it is in your
wife she has what you are seeing and
that's why the prophets are cela
practical advice no shyness in the
religion do that as a way to experian
and I must panel to Anna the most
merciful so this is like an arrow in the
heart when a person should look at
something that is not permissible so we
need to take the means the prophets are
cell and said to the young people if you
have the means the physical means to get
married get married this is the religion
of al-islam not to stay celibate without
getting made and thinking that that
pleases a lost panel Tyana no get
married be productive in the society and
protect yourself the profits are seldom
said that when a man have his relations
with his wife he gets rewards for it and
the Companions of the alarm home they
said he would get rewards while he's
fulfilling his desire the profits are
seldom said if he would do it in the
harem in a sinful way would he get us in
they said yes so he said that is so low
to Stalin so the same way if you do it
in the holland in the permissible way
you get rewards with it yeah telecheck
now where the youth and those men young
adults and they're being patient they
are worshiping the one got alone
establishing the prayer and doing all
the good wholesome things that God
Almighty Allah wants them to do but now
what advice do you give to them and the
parents because they get to an age and
now okay they're holding back those
desires you know sometimes it's very
difficult they want to get married but
the parents say you know what you need
to finish another six years of medical
school you should be the best doctor you
should be the best scientist you should
as we should be the best to benefit
mankind but now they are more concerned
about their son getting a PhD or MD but
the patients are wearing off because
we're natural human beings what about
this situation although this is a sad
situation and you just said that this
morning
if the feds I was talking with the young
brother and he was explaining the same
problem same problem same problem let's
hold off right there they say we gotta
go to break don't lose your place we
right back with this live example here
indicia all of the profits would have
been labeled because this essential
message was the same initial submission
this is God talking to you how can I
stand behind the Pope on Sunday morning
and preach a sermon that I knew was at
variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity back here on the Dean show
and before sorry we have to cut you off
had to go to break but please continue
hope you didn't lose your place after
feds afraid this morning a young Muslim
and he had the descent the look of the
Sun down his face mashallah and he was
asking me the same question the same
problem that he's young is going to
comments and all these temptations are
there and he have been practicing Islam
not too long ago and he wants to get
married but the problem is with his
parents they're telling him not before
he finishes college and so on and so
forth and this is a sad thing because we
are human beings if we ask someone to
stay away from these temptations that
it's forbidden to have a girlfriend it's
forbidden to look at someone that is not
proper clothes and so on and so forth
then we were basically ordering people
to do the impossible so that's why we
need to make it easy for them and it's a
call for the parents for the Muslim
parents have mercy on to your children
don't think when they're hiding to you
that they are tempted and they want to
fall into these types of since everybody
would say my son is not that way my
daughter is not that way they're human
beings what do you mean they're not that
way you need to help them to protect
themselves and the first thing to
protect themselves is not to tell them
feel a loss panel that of course we have
to feel a lost planet honor but as the
profits are seldom said get made he said
that she said that get married if you're
not able to get married
then fast did he try get married after
you get the PhD he didn't say that
boosts and that's why one and this is
another point that many people might
disagree with me but the pair a parent
would say but how he's going to going to
support his wife right if he is now
going to school and he's such a
well-mannered person and things like
this eventually inshallah a philosopher
not i'll give him life he will graduate
and he would work and he will make money
if he's been helped while he's doing
this if he can support his own self and
eat and drink and have a shelter another
person with him won't cost him anything
actually when we look into the means as
physical means only we are in Los there
is no difference between us and anybody
else we have the quran and sunnah of the
prophet saw said i'm teaching us there
are other set of means that people do
not know except by the revelation from
allah they means that a las panic Anna
mentioned in the Quran and one of which
Allah sanatana said in the Quran clearly
he a cool avocado yogini mulan [ __ ] if
they are poor in the context of being
made get the men and women get married
to each other if they are poor allah the
most high will make them rich out of his
bounty so he it's mentioned the quran
the same reason why people would hold
their chimeric is because their food
they don't have enough or the status and
the degree and so on a lot of Hannah
Tyler refuting is called by saying Allah
will make them rich that's where I blind
them ice road the companion of the
prophet saw said and said how can a
person hearing this verse and doesn't
get married to be rich if you want to be
rich get made it opposite to what people
say this is now a test Allah subhana
Allah is saying to you if you want to
make money if you want to be rich and
also have had a place bless your
provisions get married your provisions
will be blessed because you're obeying
the orders of a lot specially you're
getting married to protect your religion
not getting married just for the lusts
of it but to protect you release so the
parents can go ahead and do what the
Prophet said for them to do and come
together in a wholesome way in marriage
because if you know and then they can
continue school and that's a stopped
school because you got married and now
those those psychologically physically
those desires going to be met otherwise
they're going to go to the back door and
take a lot of them end up going and
doing it anyways but the wrong way and
the cell
has his ways when a person commits us in
the short run will come to him and tell
him you were a bad person you cannot
stand in a salon you need to stay away
totally from the path of Allah soprano
to alex 0 for 1 sin he would lead them
to even sometimes relegate from the D
novelist and this is another thing if a
person out of weakness fell into a sin
we need not to be despair from the mercy
of Allah soprano Donna we need to return
to a lost Hannah Tyler with repentance
and a person if he commits a sin it
doesn't mean that he abandoned the sauna
if he goes to the prayers and the
message if he needs to keep doing that
even if he committed a sin we turned to
a las panorama with repentance never
give up never give up and it's the
responsibility of the communities that
they need to support the young adults in
their community putting them together in
the same classrooms in the same
environment and we tell them you need to
stay away from each other how can that
happen this is against the human nature
we need to protect them by getting them
married and for those who are not able
to get married the advice of the
prophets are cellular too fast because
the most important thing is to save your
religion wait further for the for the
favour from Allah spinal Tala to come to
you we cannot sustain the punishment of
Allah soprano data in this life in the
unit so we want to strive like you said
earlier we're almost out of time for the
hereafter knowing def is coming as you
said and avoid argumentation stay
patient that is mentioned over you said
90 times in the quran and patient not to
go towards the boyfriend-girlfriend get
married and the parents also as you
mentioned help the children don't
impress the children last closing
comments and suggestions please our life
one of the two acts of worship that we
always in that state is patience and
being grateful to Allah subhanAllah so
we need to practice this patients is to
do what Allah span ojala odorless is not
a negative action it's something that we
are positively doing what a las panna
cotta wants from us patiently and at the
same time being grateful to him that he
gave us the life and the health and
everything like that so we need to be
patient to fulfill his orders and to
submit ourselves otherwise what
submission submission is not just in one
thing or the other submission in all of
our affairs and everything we say
everything
we do in any state that we are in we
need to be submitted to the creator of
engineer thank you very much may Allah
the creator of the heavens are rewards
you once again for being with us here
okay well yeah thank you very much young
women mashallah God was it like that and
it is so exciting I'm telling you it's
exciting this is a blessing not only for
myself being here benefiting from the
knowledge but you also you tuned in and
now you got to learn some more about the
way of life that brings you peace Islam
everything is comprehensively it's there
all you gotta do is learn it implement
it live it and keep turning back here to
the Dean show every week for a new show
and we'll see you next time God willing
until then peace be unto you he created
the universe to him along the heavens
and the earth l11 he is the first he's
the owner already eaten his messengers
to all his creatures of the great danger
Oh worshiping Allah then
there is none greater creator